well you have nailed down that you will
be doing this new bachelor show yes so
how excited are you about this and does
it make a difference that the quarantine
spurted or is it something you always
wanted to do it's something we've always
wanted to do lately I mean you have to
get to 18 years before you can say hey
we should really look back so we're a
victim of our own success in that regard
but yeah the quarantine has definitely
you know spurred this thing on and Mike
Fleiss and I started talking immediately
and thought what could we do everybody
wants content and then there was this
clamoring for old seasons of The
Bachelor and look whether you're too
young maybe you weren't born or you just
weren't on the bachelor nation train yet
but a lot of people miss some huge
pivotal seasons and so let's go back and
how do we bring this to everybody but
not just dump it online and not just let
it play out over ten weeks how do we
make it fun interesting and very
different you do see people tweeting a
lot saying drop all the old seasons give
us the seasons why not just do that well
first of all people have to understand
how the business works you don't just
drop anything that's not nut it's not
how it works I know we all have phones
and we think there's just instant
gratification but this is a business and
you can only drop things that are
purchased and so if people buy things
then they can put it on so Netflix
doesn't actually own everything in the
world so everything in the world's not
going to be on Netflix that's not how
this works people if somebody had never
even maybe seen the shows before what
would be a couple seasons you tell them
you this is gonna hook you and you're
gonna get into it on this new show since
we've made this official it's been I've
been racking my brain and drive myself
crazy over the Mount Rushmore there's
those pivotal seasons those mount
Rushmore's
like a Trista obviously the godmother
and kind of legitimized this franchise
Jason Mesnick the big switch Molly and
Melissa Sean Lowe just an iconic great
love story and then there's those
pivotal seasons that there were so many
people on it that then shot off and
became big members of our family and
important members like a Juan Pablo
Clare season you go back in
Dorfman was a bachelorette so many
people came off that Kaitlyn Bristowe a
lot of guys that became important and
influential to our franchise were on
that season so I've been racking my
brain and then there's those just
favourites of mine like a Jillian Harris
an old-school Jake Pavelka we got to
show Jake the original pilot the
original pilot also ironically a mess I
know what it is with pilots yeah maybe
they're used to being alone in a cockpit
I don't know so do you guys have it all
ironed out which seasons exactly you
know we are fighting because we're fans
like I'm a fan Mike Fleiss the creator
of the show as a fan Rob Mills is a fan
we're all fans of our own shows and
we're fighting just like you would be on
social media yeah we're gonna show
Trista yeah we're gonna show Sean Lowe
you know Kaitlyn Bristowe those are
gonna be on but then look if we're gonna
do ten maybe even more of these there's
a lot of debating that's gonna be
happening and that's the show what I
want to roll on is our zoom calls of us
yelling at each other
demanding this season is the most
important season ever well we get that
we need to I'm gonna roll on it they
don't know this yep and I'm gonna roll
on that well but some people don't want
their seasons maybe to be shown I know
Kaitlyn's kind of joked about that
before that she doesn't move you want to
relive all those moments I know Nick
vile maybe he doesn't want to see
everything from Andi Dorfman season
again Nick's been on so many seasons not
all of them can be aired there's just
too many no look revisionist history is
a wonderful thing it's like a fish story
it was this big then this big then this
big and all of a sudden you're telling
it from your perspective how cool you
are and how this thing went well now
everybody's gonna get to see how it
really went but don't worry this is all
in love this is all in fun and it's not
gonna be this long linear story like
it's going to be more bite-sized more
podcast where it's gonna be more
categories and yeah the highlights in
showing the people that made the season
so important then checking with them so
don't worry it's not gonna be that bad
but will there be some moments where
maybe a lead is reminded oh no you felt
this way at this time you know all our
memories can get a little foggy right
look and a lot of these people have kids
now and
I'm sure Trista and Ryan have shared
with their kids how things were and what
your parents were like well now they're
teenagers their kids are gonna really
get to see what they were like and and
look I'm I'm in front of all this I'm
not excited about everybody seeing a
young Chris Harrison in my oversized
suits different fit backs that's good
you were like Michael Jordan on the last
dance remember pleats were still in for
a while but that's when the guys were
those shiny collared shirts yeah it's
gonna be pretty mortifying so you're a
little nervous yeah I think there will
be emotions and things that I realize
that I'm not even sure I'm gonna know
yet and I'm gonna feel because there
this has been an emotional ride this has
been my entire professional life 18
years think about where you were 18
years ago that was a different time in
my life and so there are things in my
life that have happened my kids being
born Taylor was born while Trista was
being married and Meredith's season so
there's pivotal moments in my life that
are gonna coincide with these seasons
one person you're wanting to talk to the
most I think it's one Pablo but no I for
me it's gonna be seeing some friendly
faces and seeing you know Jason and
Molly and in talking through that and
Trista are we gonna get Chris soules
this season I don't know you know I'd
say it's on it's on the board
it this is like a draft is Chris soules
too busy quarantine in Iowa with
Victoria Fuller I don't know but
apparently there's more and more
evidence building to this relationship
well she went ahead and posted on
Instagram farm life and did her location
tag as Arlington Iowa okay well that's
probably a gimme yeah did you see the
two of them coming and knowing both of
them do you think that relationship
works I saw that coming like the
pandemic I mean nobody saw it coming
that out of the blue
no but great I I guess he slid into her
DM there's how that works don't know but
good on him man I hope they're happy and
I hope she's driving tractors around
flipping up the soybeans and all that
good stuff that's great we haven't heard
much from Chris so knowing where he's at
or what he was looking for and having
just done the season with Victoria why
do you think that worked you know I
think they both have similar paths I
think they have things they can relate
to with the
there chris is a good man I've known
Chris for a long time and loved him to
death and I do know that he was very
serious about I live in Iowa and he has
a very successful farm but he I've been
there it is in the middle of nowhere
he's not finding a Victoria out there
and so this is the only way he's gonna
find somebody so good on him and I wish
him all the best I do and however they
wanted to find it when they define it
and that's the same thing same thing
with Peter and Kelly and there was
another one I heard today Madison in
somebody and I'm like great good on you
guys you know I wish you the best well
in Victoria was somebody who really I
thought redeemed herself who in that
finale and and we saw a different side
of her and I was really rooting for her
when we got to see her speak to you the
last time I saw her was then and I gave
her a big hug and I whispered in her ear
I said you did great I was like I'm
really proud of you you really I'm like
I wish I had seen this girl and I think
that's actually what I said was where is
this girl I would have loved to have
seen her on The Bachelor and she's like
I know she's you know sometimes this
show just kind of gets the better of you
it gets you Kelly is a great example and
I think that's why maybe her and Peter
are connecting now because she didn't
perform well on the show it got the
better of her and she out thought
herself and I think Victoria did the
same thing and now maybe she is just
calm cool collected and she's finding
love with Chris great so how will you
Quarren film this oh man this has been
like a military operation the hoops we
have jumped through to make sure that
everybody is satisfied lawyers you know
heads of state you name it we really are
going to every link to make this safe
and I mean to the point of there is a
specific door at the mansion we're gonna
shoot this at the mansion that is our
hope and dream there's a specific door
that I will enter into that no one else
can go in there is a room where I can
get ready that no one else will be in
and when I go in to shoot it will be in
an empty room that will have a set
camera and set lights I will make myself
and we will start to roll and then I
will leave and there is a way I have to
leave and disinfect how I go and that's
it and then I don't see anybody I will
hear people I guess from another room so
we're very very careful and we have
color-coordinated rooms and places you
can go so and I'm glad we it's the only
way you can do this
it's gonna be very safe we won't touch
anybody we won't see anybody I will talk
to the cast and crew villa's ohm in
other forms of communication and so it's
our new life right now until we can get
back would you say this is maybe the
most complicated operation you've ever
pulled off an operation handbook that I
have received of how I need to go about
doing this from from getting my clothes
to getting makeup to arriving where I
will park when I get to the mansion I
have a designated space and then how I
will enter without being around anybody
and this it's great I'm glad that the
you know the network and the studio are
saying if you're going to do this
there's only one way we're doing it and
it has to be really safe and so we'll
abide by these rules and make it work
the best we can now how recent of
seasons will we potentially get because
it is a bit of a look-back show but
Peter sees and Colton's Hanna's those
were a huge season so Willie I doubt
we'll get into those I mean it's so
fresh and everybody's mine there's no
reason to you're not you know I think if
you're gonna do anything you would have
to flash forward with them and where
they've been doing in the quarantine so
no I think this is more about and I
don't want to put a line in the sand of
where we will go back but you know Sean
Lowe Ben Higgins I think is a great when
Kaitlyn Bristowe Rachel Lindsay great
season you may be there back is where we
would go there's gonna be 10 of these to
start I think we'll end up doing more
because I think it's gonna be a massive
overwhelming success when when everybody
gets out of this and so we'll see maybe
the more we do maybe the more recent we
get by the way I know if you saw Peter
Krause from Rachel season just did been
in Ashley's podcast did you see this no
I did not he said that he was offered
the bachelor but that he turned it down
because he was kind of seeing somebody
and he was told well you would have to
break up with that person
he said that he wanted couples
counseling and and that agreement
couldn't become too so couples
counseling for who for whoever he might
end up with him in that person okay well
they do they get that yeah okay so
everybody has access to that so what's
the real story on Peter Krause is
bachelor was he officially offered it
and he turned it down I don't know look
I don't want to poopoo on any of any of
his stories because I I didn't read it I
didn't hear him talk and he's a good guy
we do talk to a lot of people you know
that
we have a lot of candidates and we asked
them all to be the bachelor and we asked
them all to be single that's really
important like I don't know what he
thought or what he thinks or where we
were at the time because also has to do
with where we were and that in the
casting process we may have been talking
to four other people at the time for all
I know it is normal for us to have
multiple candidates coming in and then
like there will be four this greatest
hit show there's a debate it's like okay
this person we first of all we have to
find who's available who's really
sincere then we bring them in for
interviews there is a vetting process
that goes all the way up to the top of
the network so there's a lot that goes
into instead of hey Peter you want to be
the bachelor rate come on
so that would have and again not to put
a big pin in this big balloon but that
would have been the start of where we
would have gone that wouldn't have been
the final step
[Applause]
well speaking of casting I have to ask
you where things are at Clair season
because you guys have been promoting you
are casting and clear has even been get
into some social media battles with her
Clair by the way really is the
Bachelorette that is true we asked her
and she accepted know she right now it's
still up in the air as far as timing
goes again the state of California just
took a big step back who knows what's
going on so maybe we leave maybe you
have to go to a state that has their
stuff together and we can shoot who
knows
maybe we're doing this in Texas I don't
know but right now we're just waiting
and seeing until we can do it safely
until we can do it the right way and I
don't want to make this a quarantine
version I don't want it to look weird
I'm seeing a lot of stuff on TV that I'm
not loving this is an escape people want
to get away and I want to do it right
and when we can do it right we'll do it
with Claire and yeah we are recasting
still because who knows what the world's
gonna look like when we get done well
what does doing it right mean because I
think Rob Mills did do an interview and
he said you know maybe we're on lockdown
we're in a house somewhere what is doing
it right and look it's still gonna be
different
I think whatever you do it's if we're
not going to be back to normal flying
around the world and just doing what we
want but with that said I think there's
a happy medium I don't want to just lean
into the quarantine and make this feel
like hey it's the quarantine edition
we're doing it all via zoom that's not
what the shows about it's not what
people are watching it for people still
want to escape we've talked about maybe
we go to one location and lock it down
or maybe we can only travel a little bit
I don't know yet because we don't know
what the world looks like we're just
throwing out ideas nothing is definitive
but I still want it to look like The
Bachelor I want it to look like The
Bachelorette so people realize this is
my show okay I can escape I can fall
into this so Claire's season definitely
still happening as far as you know she's
the Bachelorette
[Music]
hey future husband you out there listen
to your heart is on the drama on this
show is wild like if people aren't
watching it I'm not sure they're
understanding kind of how emotional and
up and down these musicians are on this
episode Julia and Brandon why Wilde
which one of them is the bigger offender
okay first of all you're right if you
aren't watching you must and if you are
you've got to see next week's episode
Monday's episode the Brandon and
Savannah
Julia and Sheridan of it all is out of
this world I would put it up with
anything that's happened in this
franchise we've I don't think we've ever
had a female character like Julia and
you ask a question Julia and Brandon I
think they just deserve each other maybe
I don't know I don't think there is a
worse or a better between them I think
they both have their own
I mean clearly Julia was not into
Sheridan clearly she's using him to stay
around and it seemed like she was
staying around to judge Brandon and
Savannah about how they're not there for
the right reasons
it's wild there are things and I never
do this
last week I watched Monday's episode I
rewound several things about four or
five times because I couldn't believe
what was being said by Brandon and by
Julia when he called her sweetie when he
called Savannah sweetie that's just the
deck over well how the level of
condescending condescension yes and
Julia um you know and that's how she
said she makes everything about her what
do you think Julia's gonna think
watching this back I hope it's a little
bit of self-awareness I think Brandon
and Julia could use a little bit of
self-awareness when you are when you are
breaking up with somebody
and you're making them apologize and
you're saying that they're being mean
when they're being broken up with that's
a level not many people get to that's
some awareness you need in your life
that's a mirror you need held up close
I said Julie I don't listen to your
heart listen to your own words watch it
back and hear what you're saying
god bless Sheraton Sheraton wherever you
are man if you our friends and family
with Sheridan and you can get inside the
quarantine bubble give him a hug
that dude deserves a hug what would you
say to Jamie who I think said she was
gonna cry or puke about ten times on
this episode she is constantly melting
down okay first of all I'm just gonna
say I'm a fan I love my Jamie I do and I
went through this journey with her and
this was a big emotional stepping out
for her there were some just stuff she
was really uncomfortable with and it was
performing it's a performance anxiety
the dating thing there was just a lot of
things she had to overcome so I was
really proud of her okay it was a lot
there was a lot of crying and a lot of
that but at the time it made sense to us
because we were living it and going
through it but yeah now they watch it
back I'm like damn girl that was a lot
but I love I love my Jamie and Chris and
Bri seeing their first I love used to
each other on stage in front of all
those people what was that moment like
in person what a great story to tell I
said I love you in front of Toni Braxton
Andy Grammer Rachel and Brian and a
thousand spectators and what the great
part is is it was so loud in there
because we're at this big theater in LA
everybody's screaming yelling and she
stopped just like I don't think he heard
me but at the end I said I love you and
by the way good job for Chris because
that's talked about being put on the
spot he's like well if I'd heard that it
would have said I love you too
crushed it in that moment it way I'm
rushed it like a score
he had that scarf wrapped around his
neck I mean she was wrapped around his
finger it's they were and and the
moments backstage after that really felt
genuine to me when he said I really mean
it you could hear say I really know
they're the Jade and Tanner they just
went off and had their own show
like like Jaden Tanner did in paradise
they're just doing their own thing and
they are madly in love and amazing we're
like three weeks in amazing
that's when honestly to take all the
silliness away when that happens I get
this stupid grin on my face and people
were talking about it on social media
and I'm like this is what I love like
when that happens I'm like it kind of
makes it all worthwhile that's the cool
thing about this show is it works these
people are really in love and they never
would have met each other other than
this show what will happen to the listen
to your heart Tour prize
good question obviously when we made
that prize package getting out and
touring and concerts were a thing
clearly that is still part of it as soon
as they can and they can do it safely
we'll do that but yeah you know creating
music working with a music producer
music video going on tour is all
something we definitely want to do as
soon as we can safely do it but yeah how
wild that you kind of look back even
that concert you know when I'm watching
that
the concerts back I'm like wow when you
look at it through this lens of a
quarantine it's very different
[Music]